[Music]
hi
i'm jennifer and today i'm joined by
leslie from globe telecom to discuss how
they leverage google cloud's no code
platform
app sheet to empower citizen developers
leslie thank you so much for joining us
hi jennifer thank you for having me here
absolutely
all right so first question for you why
no code technology
so we introduced no code platform
because there are a lot of good
ideas that never really get into the
pipeline due to failed business case
limited project resources or just by
mere intimidation of
justifying that initiative so we see
that a no code platform can provide an
alternative path
for business process automation in
delivering applications without being
subjected to requirements
or the constraints of the standard
development process
so the smes or the end users are
able to solve their own pain points or
problems through the no code application
that's fantastic so what problems does
appsheet solve for you app sheet enables
the development of
niche applications so these are
applications that are used for specific
process
and groups in the organization
individually
they may not provide enough value to
merit building an
application in the traditional way but
these niche
applications are in the long tail and
the combined value is comparable
with the value delivered by our big or
in complex applications
so with app sheet we are able to allow
employees to automate their
own process without the need of a
developer or worrying about much of the
cost
either they find it time-consuming to
report on a service vehicle usage
or when they're on site just doing
simple data gathering
so these are issues that our frontliners
face but
never really get resolved before so
frontliners i'm definitely borrowing
that word but that aside
it sounds like working with this
platform has helped a number
address a number of the problems within
your organization but how has this
product changed how you work
so jennifer we just introduced app sheet
in our company around four months ago
and the result has been very impressive
so we conducted a no
code hackathon program as our adoption
strategy
so we invited all our employees to join
we conducted workshops
then we gave them eight weeks to
complete their application and that's on
top of their usual workload
now we saw a number of simple issues
that we didn't know still
exist and employees with no coding
background were able to
complete and build a working solution
with immediate results
now a lot of employees are reaching out
to us to learn more about app sheet
so as an example currently we are on
budgeting season
and our finance guys reach out to us to
to build an application using app sheet
so they were able to streamline the
budgeting process by just using this
platform and now when we introduce
a new process or looking into improving
our existing process
it is becoming a norm to consider app
sheet for process automation
that's amazing so what actions
have you taken to help your organization
adopt unicode technology
all right so the success of the no code
hackathon made a very good
impact in showcasing our employees the
winners
and the applications they built using
app sheet
we believe we were able to get those
early adopters
to get their insights and support for
our program
from there we also started our own globe
app sheet community
to keep that momentum going after the
buzz from the hackathon
and to increase more traction we
included
app sheet as a course in our globe
university
our globe university leads the learning
and development
across all our globe business units so
we also include some prerequisite
courses to understand the process
improvement
and basic user experience our employees
should be able to identify the overall
benefits
of the solution or application that they
plan to build
okay one last question for you leslie
since it sounds like you're ahead of the
curve when it comes to no code
technology
why should others consider adopting that
same type of technology
all right so the no code platform is not
a replacement of our software
development team
we still need to continue to create big
and complex applications to serve our
customers
and we still definitely need our it
developer
for these but there are applications in
the long tail
that are often ignored or deprioritized
so we believe that the no code platform
is the solution for those
combined with it governance no code
platform
will help speed your digital
transformation by enabling your
employees to become citizen developers
your company can solve pain points in
your process that are never elevated to
the top management
not just that the employees will also be
motivated as we empower them to create
their own applications
well leslie thank you so much for taking
the time to join us and tell your story
and for those interested in learning
more about how google cloud's no code
technology app sheet can help empower
citizen developers like you
check out the details below
you